we're following breaking news famed chef
and TV personality Anthony Bourdain has
died at the age of 61 CNN said this
morning the cause of death was suicide
Bourdain was found by a friend in a
French hotel room in a statement CNN
said his talents never cease to amaze us
and we will miss him very much
vladimir duthiers is following the story
of lad good morning good morning the
news is shocking Anthony Bourdain was a
master of his craft a renowned chef a
best-selling author and a popular
television personality he had been
dubbed the culinary bad-boy and was open
for years about his demons this country
when I first arrived here it smelled
like a place that I would like for
Anthony Bourdain food was more than
nourishment it was an identity how
African is brazilian cuisine in general
a way to understand different cultures
and people Bourdain's career took off in
1999 when as a struggling chef he wrote
an article for The New Yorker about what
happens behind the scenes in restaurants
the article became a best-selling book
Kitchen Confidential France needs me I'm
thinking now more than ever why me
because I'm a cook in 2005 he became a
household name with his travel and Food
Show no reservations bringing the world
into people's living rooms in recent
years he found a home at CNN with his
popular show parts unknown where he
explored more than just food he lit up
every room then he walked into here at
CNN Bourdain's CNN colleagues were
emotional Friday morning as they reacted
to the news of his death he was the
walking embodiment of passion Bourdain
was open about his struggle with drugs
in a 2016 interview with biography.com
he said he was one of the lucky ones
after giving up heroin in the 1980s we
made it out alive he said there are a
lot of guys that didn't get that far
Bourdain appeared on CBS this morning
throughout the years in 2012 he spoke
about his travels the world is actually
in a somewhat nicer
then I would have thought it's nice at
my age to get to learn stuff on a
regular basis CNN said Bourdain was in
France working on an upcoming episode of
parts unknown his death comes just days
after fashion designer Kate Spade died
from suicide the ability that he had to
bring together people from all
boundaries ethnicity religious national
around good libations sustenance that
was his it's it's hard to imagine
someone who had such an appetite for
life doing something like that who
seemed to have everything going for him
yeah Vlad thank you for that